So here's what we're going to do.
First thing we're going to note is
that if each of these things could be
represented by a bag of vectors max over
a bag of vectors then all the other ones
can disappear represented as
max over a bag of vectors.
So the easiest one is the very first
one the first one says that the value
function at time sub t is the max over
actions of some other kind of thing.
If this is represented as the max of a
bunch of dot products over belief states
then think about what happens if
you just take all the vectors for
all the different actions and
throw them into one big bag.
So imagine that we've got one set of
vectors that represents a value function
And then we have another set of vectors
this is for one particular action
then we have a set of vectors that
represent the value function for
different action called a2.
So the thing to note is that the max
over the bag of vectors this upper
surface Is actually the right thing.
That if a1 gives the highest answer
in one case then we get that.
If a2 gives a higher answer
in another case we get that.
We can just pull all the vectors
together so this is just a union
over all actions of the bag of
vectors for each of those actions.
This is a way of writing max as at
the operation over sets of vectors.
>> Sure I believe that,
that all makes sense.
>> The next piece is that the value
function for an action a timestamp t for
a belief state b we said that
it was the sum over observations
of some particular vector that
we get for that observation.
If these can be represented using
bags of vectors then this sum, over
observations, can also be represented
using operations over bags of vectors.
And in particular what we
wound up having to do,
is take those bags of vectors and
compute what I like to call across sum.
It's basically, the sum where we
choose for each of the observations,
we choose a vector and
then we add those factors together.
It ends up producing
the same effect as this sum.
So what we're doing here is now
given a set of vectors one set for
each action observation pair.
We're going to create a bag of vectors
just for an action by taking this
sort of cross sum, summing out
all the different observations.
Because that's really what we're doing,
we're summing out over the observations.
>> So that's just really advance what
we're writing which is you wrote.
>> Yeah but again it's just
letting us go from this function v
which is over an infinite state space
b to just a finite set of vectors.
We have a set of vectors and we generate
from that a new finite set of vectors.
So in this case the number of vectors
this first step, the number of vectors
is the sum of the size of the sum number
of the vectors In all the sets gamma at.
Here were actually multiplying,
so it's the product of the sizes
of all the sets which is finite but
it could get actually quite big.
>> Given what you say that we should
say out loud that you're making
assumptions that everything else is
finite to like the number of actions.
Sure.
That was
already built into the definition of
MDP's that we were talking about them.
>> Fair enough.
>> But yeah it's probably worth
repeating that certainly if the number
of actions is infinite
then this is problematic.
This union is problematic.
And if the number of observations
is infinite then this cross sum is
problematic.
So all but, yeah.
Finite state space, finite action space,
finite observations space.
>> Okay, so I'm getting the idea.
Basically if you can start
out with something finite
at every step of the way
you might grow but
you're never going to grow
an infinite amount in a single step.
And therefore, so long as the number
of steps is finite, or bounded or
somewhere like that you will maintain
a finite number things in your bag.
That's kind of what you're
doing that by step.
Okay.
>> That's what we're going and and
yeah and if it feels like there could
be a lot of vectors this is true
it actually can grow doubly
exponentially with t.
The number of iterations of
value iteration we're doing.
But for now we're pretending
that's not a problem.
>> Yeah, I mean look exponential is bad
unless you're comparing it to infinite.
>> [LAUGH] That's right, that's right.
We set things up so
that exponential's actually awesome.
>> Yeah, because it's finite.